pull dans la capitale aux heures les
plus chaudes les russes vide les
touristes désertent les bateaux mouches
les musées climatisé font recette
et c'est dans les endroits les plus
insolites que l'on rencontre la plus
forte affluence les catacombes
reportage elvin goldman et valérie lucas
plus de 33 degrés à paris ce jour-là
malgré la chaleur les touristes ne se
décourage pas carnaval 1 ils y vont pour
signifier à l'histoire de paris
ici on se débrouille avec la température
qui dépasse celle de la rue
en 2 4 bon il faut vite vite fermé il a
fallu fermer les salles du premier étage
la visite relève de l'exploit mais le
touriste s'adapte beaucoup de gens
passent dans le musée on va dire qu'ils
y restent moins longtemps et c'est
certain que ça fait fuir pas mal de gens
la chaleur on va moins de passionnés
arrêté par sa menue dans une salle quyi
fils le musée ferme
une heure plus tôt de toute façon les
entrées sont en baisse depuis trois
jours ça va on est décontracté il n'y a
pas trop de monde pour voir les tableaux
c'est l'idéal de l'autre côté de la
seine or c'est les touristes ont fait
une heure de queue pour contempler les
tableaux des impressionnistes dans les
salles 25 degrés devant la beauté des
oeuvres le public oublie ça fatigue
il y a deux mondes plus en réguler c'est
température et du coup les gens se
sentent bien ils se posent ils respirent
à cause de la canicule en a autorisé une
chose qu'on ne faisait pas avant c'est à
dire boire dans un musée sur la scène
les bateaux mouches ont déserté la
journée les gens doivent au pouvoir par
contre ils gagnent beaucoup plus ce soir
je serais beaucoup plus de touristes la
journée c'est normal qu'il est très
chaud même à 40 degrés la balade
conserve quand même c'est à mater le
temps il fait très chaud mais c'est
super des petits malins trouve la
fraîcheur dans les profondeurs existait
de paris sous cette chaleur c'est assez
épuisant donc à aujourd'hui mais je me
suis dit que ça serait peut-être les
catacombes
mais ici rien n'arrête ces visiteurs pas
les 14 degrés pull-over recommandé rien
sauf l'administration qui limite les
entrées ici tous les jours on refuse du
monde